Hey Wisecrack, not-a-pickle Jared here, and
today we’re breaking down the season finale
of Rick and Morty Season 3.
In this season especially, Rick and Morty continues to flaunt the meaninglessness of our existence.
Nobody gets it.
Nothing you think matters matters.
This isn't special. This - this is happening infinite times across infinite realities.
Every time the show’s teased us with a authentic
moment of love, or emotion,
it’s ripped it right out from under us.
My grandpa was my hero.
Your mom wouldn't have accepted me if I came home without you and your sister,
so now you know the real reason I rescued you. I just took over the family, Morty!
This leaves an interesting challenge for creating
a tv show: how do you have characters grow
when there is no meaning?
Well, the show gives an novel solution, that’s
a little better than just spiraling deeper into nihilism.
Guarantee you're gonna die if you touch me, and there's no afterlife everything just goes black. Don't do it.
And that growth isn’t from the titular protagonist,
but the Matriarch of the Smith family.
Welcome to this Wisecrack Quicktake on The
Rickchurian Mortydate.
And, of course, spoilers ahead.
Ok, so first a quick recap: Rick and Morty
are called in to help the president with some
X-Files shenanigans, but soon bore of helping
out the leader of the free world.
Rick and the president begin an ever-escalating
dick-waving contest, the two unleash their
vast arsenals against each other, before Rick
has a more pressing matter to attend to: Jerry.
Oh! Damnit.
The more interesting subplot, however, is Beth’s.
Fresh off the events of Episode 9, Beth begins
to question whether or not she had taken Rick’s
offer to be replaced by a clone,
and if she, in fact, is the clone.
To settle the matter, she seeks the help of
Jerry who recreates one of their first dates
and rekindles their love. But still worried
she’s gone Blade Runner, Beth runs off to
the woods with the family, where Rick shows
up to kill Jerry and convince her that she’s not a clone.
In our last quicktake, we talked about Rick
informing Beth of what her intelligence actually means.
"Am I evil?
Worse. You’re smart.
When you know nothing matters the universe is yours and I’ve never met a universe that was into it."
Rick’s answer to all of this, as we know
know, is “Don’t think about it.”
Faced with this, Beth is given radical freedom
to choose her destiny.
And this freedom brings her solace about her
choice to stay with, or leave, her family
- regardless of which choice she makes.
"I don't know if I can do it.
Then stay and luxuriate in a life you can finally know you've chosen.
My secret bonus is that no matter what you choose you're finally gonna chill the f*** out."
But this episode SEEMS to
suggest that she chose to stay,
"Beth, you crazy bitch, you're my daughter."
and has a newfound sense of happiness.
She’s being a better mother to Summer, sort of,
"I just put it on for fun. I know I can't buy it.
Oh come on, you look great! You're only young once.
Just promise if the results are too
strong you'll use protection."
finally loves Jerry, and has brought her
family back together.
"We're a real family now. In many
ways things will be like season 1."
But for some, it may seem kind of...weird
that she just suddenly rekindles her love
with the helpless parasite that is Jerry.
We could apply some of the philosophical themes
we’ve identified in earlier quick takes
here: Sartre’s bad faith and radical freedom,
alienation vs agency.
But I’m going to propose something a little
new to explain why Beth reconnects with Jerry
and her overall paradigm shift.
Amor Fati - the cure for common nihilism.
Now, what really made me think of this is this moment:
Beth, worried she’s a clone, must now confront
and question her past.
Not only is she still thinking about Rick’s
original proposition - the ability to flee
her past - but as a possible clone, are
those memories even her own, and what does
that mean for her future, or her happiness?
Amor Fati is a latin phrase Freddy Nietzschmeister
used that means “Love of Fate.”
Amor Fati is about the affirmation of life,
being what Nietzsche called a “Yes-Sayer,”
not to be confused with the pervasive corporate
“Yes-Man”, and it’s tied to a thought
experiment many refer to as “Eternal Recurrence.”
To simplify, imagine a demon shows up and
says he’s going to groundhog day your whole life.
Do you get thrown into an existential despair
because you have to infinitely relive questionable
life moments like the popularity of Smash Mouth
and frosting your tips in middle school, or
do you, to paraphrase Nietzsche, high-five
the demon
and say you’ve never heard anything more divine.
To want to relive everything that’s happened
in your life for eternity - the good, the
bad, and everything in between, is the ultimate
affirmation of life, it’s amor fati.
And it’s part of Nietzsche’s grand plan
to escape the crushing nihilism of existence.
Given Beth’s existential crisis and proclivity
for Rick-like disillusionment-causing intelligence,
Beth has to confront her past.
"I came to you for help and now I'm insulting your intelligence and look where intelligence gets you!"
And, with Jerry, she gets to re-live a small
part of it..
"I just thoughtt f*** it! Lips don't sweat!"
And while she may have hated her life the
first time around, including, her date with
Jerry, this time around she’ll be that
Nietzschean Yes-Sayer.
But I don’t think Beth is rewriting the past, either.
She doesn’t deny the years of misery she has endured.
Amor Fati isn’t about some kind of “everything
is a blessing in disguise,” but it's more about not to shun
the ugly aspects of our lives.
As she tells Jerry, she’s no longer the
woman he married, And sure, Jerry may be an idiot,
*whisper* loooosssserrr
but maybe “simplicity” is what
a person with a family history of using intelligence
to justify sickness needs.
We see another amor fati-esque moment when
Beth thinks Rick has come to retire her:
Brushing aside the Blade Runner-yness of it
all, Beth is also functionally saying: Yes, a
version of Beth may have chosen to leave,
but I embrace being left with my family rather
than dwell on what could have been.
And, if you’ll let me extrapolate a bit,
while there might be infinite universes where
Rick and Beth have made infinitely different
choices, she wants to stay in this one.
As Nietzsche says
While Nietzsche didn’t necessarily philosophize
about infinite realities, he did write about
the impossible task of “knowing oneself.”
"I'm out of excuses to not be who I am. So, who am I?
What do I do?"
Beth doesn’t know who she is, but desperately wants to.
For Nietzsche, the logic of why we actually
do anything is impenetrable.
And, if we want to apply this Nietzschean
framing to Rick, we the fans almost never
know what actually drives him.
"Why would you do that for me?
I don't know. Maybe you matter so little that I like you. Or maybe, it makes you matter. Maybe I love you."
So while Beth can fret about whether or not
she chose to be cloned, or whether or not
any of it matters in the infinite versions
of herself, Nietzsche would say it really doesn’t
matter - all we can do is love our fate.
And that seems to be the choice Beth has made.
And to me, this is really interesting, because
while the show has often portrayed Rick as
a kind of Nietzschean ubermensch at war with
the meaningless cosmos.
There is no God! In your face!
But Rick, in a quite un-Ubermenschy way,
doesn’t really create
his own new meaning as much as he just kind
of dicks around in the most self destructive
way possible.
Beth, on the other hand, when faced with the
meaninglessness of the cosmos, finds happiness.
And that’s pretty ubermenschy, if you ask me.
Now, if you’re like me and don’t know
what to do with yourself now that you have
to wait probably forever for season 4, consider
checking our Wisecrack podcast, The Squanch.
Where we broke down every episode of season 3.
Over the break, we’ll be breaking down older
episodes, engaging a lot more with your questions,
and trying desperately to interview anyone
who works on the show.